DON DODGE: Hi, I'm Don
Dodge, and this
is Google Root Access.
Our topic today is advisory
boards and how
they can help you.
We had such a good time
last time that we
decided to do it again.
My guest today is David Weekly,
a longtime friend.
David is the founder of PB Wiki,
founder of Hacker Dojo,
advisor to many companies,
and start-up entrepreneur
extraordinaire.
Welcome, David.
DAVID WEEKLY: Thanks!
It's good to be here.
DON DODGE: Great.
So we want to talk about
advisory boards.
You've been an advisor to
start-ups, and you've had
advisory boards that
advise you.
Tell us a little bit about some
of those experiences and
some of the good experiences
you've had.
DAVID WEEKLY: Sure.
So, I think it's been
tremendously helpful for me to
be able to tap into the wisdom
of people who've been there,
done that--
people who have seen the movies,
as it were, of what
I'm going through, and are able
to give insight about
what's a good idea and
what's a bad idea.
It took me a little while to
get used to using advisors.
I was thinking that, as an
engineer, when I struck out on
my own, I would just figure
out everything by myself.
Because that's how I had
figured out a lot of
computing, was just by playing
around with the computer by
myself and checking online
resources where I could.
And I didn't realize how
powerfully helpful it would be
to be reaching out to advisors
for help on my situation.
DON DODGE: So founders figure
everything out themselves,
developers figure it out
themselves, that's sort of in
their nature.
DAVID WEEKLY: That's right.
DON DODGE: But when you think
you already know the answer,
do you go to advisors just to
get validation, or to get a
different set of eyes?
So how do you reach out to
advisors, even when you think
you already know?
DAVID WEEKLY: I think
it's good to
double-check your work.
And I think that's a good
engineering practice in
general anyhow.
It's why code reviews
make sense.
And this is kind of
like code reviews
for important decisions.
So just trying to lay out
to another person--
this is where I'm at, this is
why I'm making this decision,
this is why this seems like
an obvious thing to me.
Just lay out your axioms.
And the very process of
explaining your thinking to
another person is always a good
idea, because it forces
you to make concrete those
assumptions that otherwise you
wouldn't have to spell out.
DON DODGE: So a code reviewer
designer, that's an excellent
analogy to an advisory board.
What kinds of topics do you
take to an advisory board?
DAVID WEEKLY: So I think it's
everything from what should we
be focused on right now, when
should we take financing, what
should the structure of that
financing be, when should we
consider an acquisition
offer--
basically just taking a look
strategically at the company
and the key decisions that
you need to make.
And vetting them to a set
of experienced people.
DON DODGE: And how often do
you reach out to them?
Do you have a routine, like once
a week or once a month,
or a monthly meeting,
or as needed or--
how do you work that?
DAVID WEEKLY: So I personally
don't have a lot of
formalized, calendared structure
with my advisors.
I reach out to them on
an as-needed basis.
And the result of that is that
there can be a couple months
where not very much is going
on, and I'll just send an
email blast update to them,
letting them know
how things are going.
And there are periods of time
when I'll need them very
aggressively and be interacting
with them,
sometimes multiple
times a day.
So that I think maps much better
to what start-ups need,
because sometimes they're just
heads down building product.
It's relatively straightforward
what to do.
And sometimes there's very
important decisions that are
pivotal to the success of the
company that are going to need
a lot of advisory input, in
situations that are developing
very quickly, like around a
financing round or like around
an acquisition.
DON DODGE: So you run Hacker
Dojo, and you have hundreds
and hundreds of developers who
are working there, always
seeking advice.
What kinds of advice do you
give to them versus a more
formal advisor relationship?
When do you know that it's time
to formalize an advisory
relationship?
DAVID WEEKLY: So I think that
the first meeting should
always be free.
It's similar to if
you're engaging a
start-up lawyer, right?
So, I'll try to have a pretty
open door for interesting
people who need some help and
who are reaching out.
There are some cases in which
the start-up that they're
working on is so far afield
and the situations that
they're facing are so far afield
from what I know how to
provide useful advice for
that I'll just punt.
I'll say I'm very sorry, I wish
you the best of luck, but
I can't help you with this.
Most the time I will try
to help them out
over email as a start.
If that goes well, if I'm kind
of excited by what they're
doing, I'll invite them to come
meet me in person for
half an hour to an hour.
And if that goes well, and they
come back a second, a
third time, it's usually at that
point that we'll start
exploring formally codifying
the advisory relationship.
Then usually the way that that
works is, it's not cash-based
because these start-ups
don't have any cash.
A lot of these guys are
living on friends'
couches and so forth.
So it's on an equity basis.
The standard advisory contract
here in Silicon Valley is for,
ballpark, about half a percent,
vesting over two
years on a monthly basis,
with full acceleration
on change of control.
And that last provision, I've
actually run into trouble
before as an advisor, where
one of the companies I was
advising ended up getting
purchased--
by Google incidentally--
and because I didn't have that
provision in, I only got paid
a very small amount of it.
But, yeah, that's generally the
structure of these things.
And then if the advisor is not
able to continue providing
helpful coaching advice is not
available for the start-up,
the start-up can just terminate
the advisory agreement.
DON DODGE: Right.
So just to put a little more
definition on that for our
viewers, you say over two years,
and it vests monthly.
DAVID WEEKLY: Yes,
that's right.
DON DODGE: So that means you
get 1/24 of that stock.
DAVID WEEKLY: Correct.
DON DODGE: So it's not like
employee stock options, which
sometimes have a one
year cliff--
DAVID WEEKLY: That's right.
DON DODGE: --where you have to
stay one year to get anything.
DAVID WEEKLY: That's right.
DON DODGE: With advisors
it's every
month they get something.
DAVID WEEKLY: That's right.
That's the typical
arrangement.
Some advisory agreements might
have like a six month cliff in
there, but a one-year cliff, or
a four year contract, are
kind of unusual in the
advisory realm.
A lot of that is just because
the kind of advice that you're
going to need for the next two
years could substantially
differ from the kind of
advice that you'll
need two years hence.
DON DODGE: Right, longer-term.
And acceleration means
that if you get
acquired before that two-year--
DAVID WEEKLY: The advisor
gets all their stock.
DON DODGE: They get all of it.
DAVID WEEKLY: Right.
Because the acquiring entity is
probably not going to want
to retain the advisory
relationship, and as a result
the advisor will lose that
part of their stock.
DON DODGE: How do you
find good advisors?
DAVID WEEKLY: That's
a tough question.
It's very similar to how do
you find good employees.
You want to find people with
whom you have good rapport,
who you trust, who are
well-respected in the
community, so you can
backchannel them and you get
positive results.
For me, my first board member,
who is also my first advisory
board member, was the best boss
I had as a summer intern
in college.
I really liked this guy.
I really respected this guy.
So I kept in touch with him.
And when it came time for me to
start a company I asked him
to join my advisory board.
Similarly, when I was first
starting my company, I
produced some interesting
technical products that caught
the attention of a guy who had
created a company previously
in the same space.
He reached out to me and said,
hey did you license my
company's software?
I said no, I built it myself.
He said we need to meet.
So then the two of us met, and
we began a long-standing
relationship.
And I was able to backchannel
him very positively.
So I think usually the
biggest thing is do
you have good rapport?
Are they able to give you useful
advice right away in
that first meeting?
And do they backchannel well?
And if all those things match
up, then I think exploring an
advisory relationship
makes sense.
DON DODGE: And so advisors,
do you commonly know them
beforehand?
Or you get introductions
to them?
Or they're industry heavyweights
that you really
want their advice and you
don't know them at all?
So over your experience where
do your advisors come from?
DAVID WEEKLY: Generally, they
are people I have some degree
of social overlap with, and I
think they would be able to
offer unusual insight into the
market that I'm looking at.
For instance, the two-man
company that I'm currently
running, when we were looking
at the financial services
space, we brought on board some
advisors who had a lot of
experience there.
When we decided that that wasn't
the area that we are
going to pursue, that instead
we're going to focus on family
sharing, we actually dropped
those advisors and took new
advisors who had experience in
the family sharing space.
So folks like the founders of
Ecomom and Circle of Moms and
some influential
mommy bloggers.
So we brought those folks on
board instead, because they
were able to offer unusual
insight into how to get into
that market.
DON DODGE: Interesting.
I know both of those
guys very well.
It's an interesting story.
Should you try to get the
industry heavyweight, the big
person that everyone knows, or
should you try to get people
who you trust and can confide in
on difficult issues, or do
you look for balance?
DAVID WEEKLY: I would
look for a balance.
I think a lot of people seek to
get big brand name people
without a real understanding
of what that person would
actually be able to add,
other than their name.
Right?
So Eric Reese, for instance, has
a lot of people who reach
out to him.
They want to be able to list
him as a formal advisor
without really understanding
that Eric is quite busy
couldn't possibly advise
thousands and
thousands of companies.
That wouldn't really be a
meaningful relationship.
And so I think he, anticipating
that those people
are likely to be disappointed,
would turn many of those down,
if they didn't come through
in some way vetted.
I think, analogously, Y
Combinator, a lot of people
applied because they think
they'll be able to get good
advice and mentorship from Paul
Graham and are somewhat
bitterly disappointed to find
out that, actually, PG's quite
busy, and you don't get extended
periods of hands-on
mentorship from him.
So I think it can be dangerous
to go right after the top end
of the curve.
I think where I've seen a lot
more systematic success is
looking for people who have
unusual insights in the
industry that you're getting
into, who are maybe
second-tier, who are not all
over the media all day every
day, but who really know their
field and within their field
are very well-connected and
very well-respected.
So tracing through to those
specific people is a lot
easier and you'll generally find
that you're second-degree
from them, worst case
third-degree from them, and
it's not that hard to
network to them.
What I sometimes face is new
entrepreneurs coming to me
with blanket requests--
do you know anyone who would
be able to advise a
company like mine?
Those kind of requests are
very likely to fail.
It could be that I just had
lunch yesterday with somebody
who'd be perfect to advise the
company, but the odds of that
are very, very low.
I tend to find that when
companies have a very specific
ask, like, hey you seem to know
Jason who's really deep
in AWS, and has a broad
experience there.
I think he would be perfect
to advise our company.
I've prepared these two
paragraphs to explain why I
think Jason would be a perfect
fit for our company.
Could you forward that
along to him?
That's going to get a 100% hit
rate, because they've done the
research to figure out what
resources they need, why they
need them, and why that
person would be ideal.
So I usually coach people,
be specific in what
you're asking for.
Be specific in what you're
hoping for, and you'll find
that it's quite easy
to actually get it.
DON DODGE: So that's a good
segue into how to
use advisory boards.
You have to be specific
in what you ask them.
I get requests all the time,
hey, let's go have coffee.
I don't have time to go have
coffee, but if you ask me a
specific question then
I can answer it.
So say a little bit about how
you work with your advisory
board members, and the kinds of
requests, and how you make
it a very specific ask.
DAVID WEEKLY: So, for instance,
let's say you're
managing a financing
round, right?
And you have one or two VCs who
are on the table in-bound
and you want to make sure that
you get a couple more in play.
And you might have some specific
ideas about what VCs
would be helpful.
Even presenting a list of, hey,
these four VCs, I would
love to go and meet with them.
They seem like they're investing
in this space,
they're well reputed.
Do you guys have connections
at one of these four VCs?
That's also likely to get a
pretty high hit rate, because
you're giving straightforward
homework in that sense to your
advisory board.
It's a little less likely to
succeed if you just sort of
broadcast out, like, hey,
could you connect
me with some VCs.
Dear group, right?
You might get some hits on that,
but the more specific,
the higher the response
rate is going to be.
DON DODGE: And again, being
specific with advisors, you
might want an advisor who's
great at growth hacking, or
monetization, or someone
who's great
social media and marketing.
So you figure out what you need,
the kind of help you
need, and then you target
specific individuals who you
think can help.
DAVID WEEKLY: Especially
where you're weak.
I think a great leader is not
great in all dimensions, but
they understand in what
dimensions they are not great,
and then they figure out ways
to have that not matter,
either by focusing their company
in other areas, or
having other people go and shore
up their weaknesses.
And that's true in terms of
employment, finding people to
hire and work with that are good
at the things you're not
good at, and in terms of
advisors, people who can help
you see in your blind spots.
DON DODGE: Right.
What are some of the don'ts,
some of the things you should
avoid in setting up an advisory
board or choosing advisors?
DAVID WEEKLY: Sure.
I mean, I don't think that you
need a giant panel of people.
I don't think that the goal is
to have 15 people who come
over to your house once a
month kind of a thing.
I generally found that the
quality of feedback is best
one on one, and ideally
in person.
Sometimes you can't do that.
Sometimes you can get a
lot done over email.
But the best sessions
do happen in person.
They do happen one on one.
So I would say pick on the order
of five advisors who can
help fill out your own strengths
and weaknesses, and
seek to meet with them one on
one, and to present to them
how your company is doing and
how you are thinking about the
important decisions that
your company is facing.
I would say an advisor that asks
you for a cash retainer
should be a pretty
big red flag.
An advisor who on your first
meeting has lots of specific
ideas about what kind of equity
slice they would like,
in like the 5 to 10% kind of
range particularly, should be
giant red flags.
I wish somebody had told me
that when starting out.
You'll find that there are some
general pools in which
they are higher quality
advisors.
So get mentors, for
instance, who are
part of Founder Institute.
That tends to be pretty
high quality pool.
And there's also some low
quality pools, like I find
that a number of angel groups
have people who are circling
sharks, looking for naive
first-time entrepreneurs and
ways to exploit them.
So I think pay careful attention
to what pools in
which you're fishing for
high-quality advisors.
DON DODGE: So an advisory
relationship is a two-way
street, right?
To make it work takes input
from both sides.
So I've seen cases where a
start-up has recruited some
advisors, but then doesn't
reach out to
them, doesn't use them.
Or, conversely, the start-up
is reaching out to the
advisor, but they're
not responding.
So how do you manage
those things?
And I think you mentioned
earlier, these agreements are
cancelable.
So if it's not working, you can
cancel it and start over.
DAVID WEEKLY: That's right.
DON DODGE: But.
What techniques have used
it to make it a good
relationship both ways?
How often do you reach out?
That kind of thing.
DAVID WEEKLY: I think at the
very least, sending a ballpark
monthly update to your
investors, advisors, et
cetera, saying hey, this is
where the company is at, this
is what we're building, this
is the result of the stuff
that we've done so far, this is
how things are coming on,
this is what we're planning
for the next month, here's
what we said we were doing last
month, and here's how it
actually turned out.
That will keep you honest.
And oftentimes people will find
ways to weigh in on that
that can be helpful.
But certainly doing that kind of
at least a monthly check in
with advisors is good to be able
to keep them up to date
with where you're at.
So that when you do reach out to
them, for say a one on one
meeting, they know where
you're coming from.
They've gotten the background
on that, and you can right
away get to the heart
of the matter.
I would say making sure that
you reach out to them
individually every other month
at least, and once a quarter
you should be sitting
down with them.
And if you can't get a face to
face meeting sitting down with
an advisor at least once a
quarter, you should probably
drop them because they're
too busy.
DON DODGE: I'm an advisor to
several companies myself, and
I've found that when the CEOs
send us that monthly update,
they're not asking for any help
particularly, but they
might say, oh I'm in the process
of doing a deal with
XY Company, or I'm in the
process of talking to this VC
about raising money.
I read that, and I say, oh, I
know the CEO of that company,
or oh, I know a partner
in that firm.
So you get help without
asking for it really.
DAVID WEEKLY: By making sure
that people are in the loop as
to what's going on.
If they're not in the loop, if
you haven't kept them up to
date with what's going
on, they have no
idea how to help you.
advisors want to help you.
This is actually another
interesting thing, is that
networkers want to network.
It makes them feel good.
Connectors want to connect.
And advisors want to advise.
I think a lot of first time
entrepreneurs are very shy
about imposing themselves on
others, and so they don't want
to reach out and give people
updates, because I'm sure he
gets a lot of email.
They don't want to go and ask
for a specific networking
request, because that would be
imposing on this person who
they know who's a very
good networker.
They don't realize that actually
what they're doing is
validating that other
person's existence.
In asking an advisor for input
and actually listening to that
input, you're giving them
meta-feedback that you are a
good advisor, you are helpful
as an advisor.
And that makes the advisor feel
really good, and feel
like, ah, my time is being
well spent here.
DON DODGE: Exactly.
DAVID WEEKLY: So don't
be afraid to reach
out for those resources.
DON DODGE: So two highlights
that I've gotten from you in
this discussion is one, reach
out to your advisors with
general updates of things
that are going on.
You may get help that you
didn't even ask for.
And the second one is, when you
do reach out for help, be
very specific about what the
ask is, so that they can
either handle it themselves
or directed to
somebody else who can.
DAVID WEEKLY: That's right.
DON DODGE: Any other advice?
DAVID WEEKLY: Go in
and get advice.
Don't be a one man army who
thinks you can figure out
everything yourself.
You exist in the ecosystem.
The more that you can respect
that, and connect with other
people, the more benefit
you'll get.
But then, on the other side of
that, you already, in starting
a company, have experience
that's
helpful to other people.
You may not think of yourself as
an advisor-- you may think
of yourself as an advisee,
looking for a good advisor--
but don't forget that it's
turtles all the way down.
And in order to be a productive
part of this
ecosystem, I think everyone
who participates should be
looking for ways that they
themselves can share and
contribute back.
And it's never too early to be
a productive part of the
ecosystem, finding somebody
that you can help in a
meaningful way.
DON DODGE: Thank you, David.
This has been a tremendous
discussion.
I really enjoyed it.
And thank you for joining us
on Google Developers Live,
Root Access.
Please check the schedule and
come back again when our next
show we'll be talking about
another important topic.
Thank you very much.